hola qué tal yo soy side by one mejor
conocido en las redes como el hombre
robot y el día de hoy antes de iniciar
esta charla quiero pedirles que se tomen
unos segundos conmigo para cerrar los
ojos e imaginarse
como creen que será el futuro
y listo
déjenme decirles que probablemente el
futuro que nos imaginamos
se trata en realidad del pasado
hoy día tenemos por ejemplo robots
fabricando casas en la luna yo trabajaba
en el laboratorio en el que estaba en el
programa de doctorado en eeuu que se
estaba desarrollando esta tecnología
vivimos en un mundo en el que en nuestra
empresa en méxico le ponemos prótesis
robóticas a humanos hayward que mueven
con el pensamiento a través de
electrodos que se ponen en su cabeza en
este mundo no dejan a las personas que
usan prótesis de pierna de competir en
las olimpiadas contra usain bolt porque
le ganarían muy muy fácilmente
la humanidad está creando seres humanos
modificados genéticamente para ser
resistentes a enfermedades y más
inteligentes
alfaz para los lectores de aldous huxley
en un mundo feliz
[Música]
no nos damos cuenta de que el mundo es
así cuando el futuro es el pasado y que
en realidad se ve como una ola de
'tsunami' cuando vemos una imagen como
esta posiblemente no nos dimos cuenta
desde el principio que la vimos que en
realidad ya está arrasando con las casas
que están cerca del tsunami siempre
pensamos la ola no es tan grande se va a
quedar en la playa
yo estoy lejos falta mucho para que
llegue a mí pero en realidad la ola está
avanzando a una velocidad mucho más
grande de lo que podemos entender esto
se debe a lo que se llama la ley de
moore que dice y se ha cumplido que
vamos a tener cada año y medio
computadoras los doble de rápidas por el
mismo costo y esto como nos afecta pues
que antes una computadora era del tamaño
de todo este auditorio y costaba cientos
de miles de dólares y ahora todos
tenemos computadoras mucho mucho más
potentes en nuestros bolsillos
esa democratización y ese acceso es lo
que estaba pasando con prácticamente
todas las tecnologías como por ejemplo
en mi área de experiencia y la impresión
3d que todo el mundo pensamos que es una
tecnología nueva cuando en realidad es
de esta época
y esto me lleva a la tecnología que más
va a tener impacto en el futuro de la
vida de todas las personas posiblemente
va a trascender a nivel de nuestra
especie y es la inteligencia artificial
nosotros antes veíamos robots como este
y ahora
al pasar del tiempo 70 años después de
que se inventa la inteligencia
artificial empezamos a ver cosas como
esto
esa cara siempre es me da muchísimo
miedo
el caso es
que esto tiene que ver con el poder del
procesamiento que tienen las
computadoras cada vez tienen el doble de
recursos a su disposición y por cómo
funcionan los algoritmos de inteligencia
artificial la capacidad de cómputo con
la que cuentan determina prácticamente
su nivel de inteligencia se pueden hacer
mejoras al software a como la
computadora aprende pero al final del
día esto es muy importante y pareciera
que hoy día no tenemos nada de qué
preocuparnos si esa robot no nos puede
cumplir su promesa porque aunque
juntemos miles de computadoras ninguna
es tan poderosa como la computadora que
tenemos entre las orejas
y nos podríamos poner técnicos pero en
realidad podemos entenderlo simplemente
imaginando nos que esa computadora está
en este momento moviendo robots muy
complejos que podemos balancear nos
sobre nuestras extremidades que estamos
procesando vídeo en super alta
definición de nuestros ojos guardando lo
en streaming en nuestra memoria mientras
nos estamos preguntando cómo rayos será
el futuro sin perder un solo latido de
nuestro corazón
y es que aunque el cerebro humano tiene
estas capacidades gracias a literalmente
millones de años de evolución
las computadoras no llevan aprendiendo
cómo pensar más de 100
y esto es bastante evidente porque
mientras nosotros pensamos de forma
lineal las máquinas si piensan de forma
exponencial como fueron planeadas y esto
podemos notarlo con un ejemplo
imagínense que yo parto de este círculo
rojo en pueblo
y que doy un primer paso de un metro
después de un siguiente paso de dos
metros el siguiente de cuatro y cómo voy
duplicando para mejorar tantos pasos voy
a dar 32
podríamos pensar que al terminar estos
32 pasos llegaría a la entrada del
edificio al centro del pueblo que podría
regresar a mi laboratorio incio de
mexico pero lo cierto es que después de
32 pasos llegarían las vegas nevada
por después de haberle dado 100 vueltas
a la tierra que son las vueltas que nos
va a dar la inteligencia artificial
después de 32 de estos ciclos esto pues
va a tener implicaciones muy evidentes
en cómo funcionan los trabajos los
primeros que lo notaron fueron los
vendedores que tuvieron que cambiar la
forma en la que trabajaban en un mundo
en que la mayoría de las transacciones
están cerrando en línea directamente con
una plataforma y ya ese trabajo de
convencimiento parece ser innecesario y
los está haciendo migrar
pero en realidad ya hay robots
periodistas que escriben artículos para
the gardian o que podrían haber escrito
el script de esta charla
hay robots artistas que componen música
o que hacen pinturas con un gran test
habíamos visto robots abogados o
robots que programan robots
entonces podríamos pensar después de
todo lo que estamos diciendo que la
tecnología es terrible que nos va a
dejar sin trabajos que como podemos
parar este tsunami
cuando quiero pedirles que ahora se
pongan en la situación en la que tal vez
su madre esté en una mesa quirúrgica y
la única posibilidad de salvarla sea que
un robot con mucha precisión le haga
esta cirugía
realmente les gustaría que no existe
este robot y esta es la decisión a la
que se están enfrentando las personas
que desarrollan robótica todos los días
al final del día podemos imaginarnos un
futuro mucho más utópico un futuro de
abundancia en el que los robots tomen
todos los trabajos pero que en realidad
esto nos haga más independientes que
sean más eficientes que generen comida
para todos que la puedan distribuir de
forma eficiente esa ha sido la promesa
de la tecnología como para los que
vieron en esta película que parecía
triste porque los humanos eran inútiles
y estaban gordos que en realidad pues no
tiene que ser algo necesariamente real
si las máquinas nos hacen todo
al mismo tiempo nos está dando la
promesa de terminar con el hambre todo
el mundo junto con manufactura
sostenible energías renovables tenía
acceso a la cobertura de todas sus
necesidades sin tener que trabajar
que no daríamos por poder erradicar el
hambre en el mundo la pobreza es una
crisis que azota desafortunadamente el
mundo
y aunque esto pareciera contradictorio
lo cierto es que la tecnología así nos
ha dado más recursos en realidad la
clase media hoy día es más rica que el
rey promedio del siglo 17
nosotros tenemos por ejemplo si un día
queremos tomar una carroza pues nos está
esperando allá afuera que quieres
subirte a un
castillo europeo y que después al día
siguiente quieres dormir en otro pues
los rentas en una plataforma y viajas en
low cost mucho más como de lo que
hubiera viajado ese rey
la clase media tiene más zapatos que el
rey promedio tuvo en el siglo 17 después
de la primera revolución industrial y
definitivamente hay menos pobres en el
mundo que en la época de esos reyes
entonces pareciera que la tecnología en
realidad se ha ayudado y que si nos está
guiando a ese futuro de abundancia pero
al mismo tiempo lidiamos con este
sistema económico que haría parecer que
como en el juego de monopoly
quien tiene a los primeros robots va a
ir ganando poder influencia y esto va a
seguir haciendo que esto se perpetúe y
que quien va a garantizar que todos
tengamos acceso a esos alimentos a esa
salud que la tecnología nos podría
brindar y esta es la verdadera pregunta
porque así como podríamos tener un
futuro utópico como el de esa película
el futuro se podría ver algo así
porque que nos hace pensar que los
robots van
seguir siendo nuestros esclavos por
tanto tiempo cuando suponemos que va a
llegar el punto en el que van a poder
pensar a nuestro nivel o en realidad de
una forma superior
la respuesta única que se ocurre y se
plantea por como esto parece como un
tsunami que viene y que es imposible de
detener
unírseles
en lugar de extinguir nos trascendamos
como especie de convertirnos en estos
robots sapiens mezclados con estos
robots porque así como
hace cinco años que hablaba de chips en
el cerebro y de transferencia de
conciencias y de inteligencia artificial
teniendo impacto en nuestras vidas y
parecía que era algo que no iba a pasar
está proyectado que una computadora
piensa el nivel de toda la humanidad
junta para 2045 y todos los hitos de lo
que he venido diciendo se han ido
cumpliendo perfectamente en tiempo
esto nos lleva a pensar cómo va a ser
nuestra interacción con estos robots con
estos robots más eficientes con estos
robots más fuertes y es que tenemos que
entender qué es lo que realmente
llamamos estar vivos
digo podríamos pensar que estar vivos es
la preservación de nuestros cuerpos es
lo que buscamos con la tecnología por
ejemplo la de la salud pero seguramente
una persona que pierda una extremidad en
un accidente y se le pone un brazo robot
sigue estando viva qué pasaría si esa
prótesis en realidad
repusiera una parte perdida de su
cerebro que mantuviera su conciencia
exactamente como era sin modificar nada
entonces podemos pensar que el cerebro
no debería de ser tocado pero al mismo
tiempo
podríamos pensar que en realidad lo que
hace esa persona es la mente porque qué
pasaría si perdiera todas sus
extremidades órganos y todos fueran
siendo repuestos uno por uno menos el
cerebro entonces podríamos pensar que
tenemos que preservar esa mente pero qué
pasaría si esa mente pudiéramos
preservarla completamente en un entorno
virtual copiarla y descargarla esa
persona sigue estando viva en ese
entorno virtual
qué pasaría si sigue habiendo esa
conciencia en el cuerpo físico que dejó
cuando fue copiada
entonces podríamos pensar que lo que nos
hace especiales y estar vivos es tener
un alma
pero en realidad que es un alma tal vez
es un producto de nuestra conciencia que
creamos para sentirnos especiales y
diferentes ante estas máquinas que así
como nuestro cerebro también son materia
altamente organizada que tiene la
capacidad de pensar y racionalizar y en
algún punto hacerse la pregunta que hago
aquí y cuál es mi propósito esto se
mezcla con el hecho de que estos robots
cuando lleguen a este punto podríamos
considerarlos hiper capacitados por
poner un ejemplo y no me gusta la
palabra hoy día el término es que se
considera que existen personas
discapacitadas alguien que tiene por
ejemplo una discapacidad visual o motriz
pero estas personas
quiere decir que entonces tendríamos que
tener un estándar que consideraríamos
capacitado
qué pasaría cuando estas personas
empiecen a usar de aumentación es para
incrementar esas capacidades tendríamos
que llamarlas hiper capacitadas y eso es
algo
ya está ocurriendo personas cyborg
existen hace mucho no sólo usando
prótesis por ejemplo quien usó un
marcapasos literalmente se está
mezclando con una máquina para poder
seguir viviendo y esto es de hace mucho
que va a pasar cuando querramos
cambiarnos los brazos por unos que nos
den súper fuerza o que querramos cambiar
partes de nuestro cerebro para poder
acceder a internet con el pensamiento y
controlar las cosas todo esto son cosas
con las que nos vamos a enfrentar de
forma cotidiana antes de lo que pensamos
yo por ejemplo en el trabajo como
ingeniero cuando estoy desarrollando
nuevas placas de circuito se me hizo muy
fácil que si ya hago brazos robot porque
no ponerme un tercer brazo y así poder
agarrar un componente mientras agarro la
herramienta caliente y la soldadura para
poder terminar estas placas con mayor
facilidad
quien haya soldado sabrá que sería
bastante útil en realidad y son cosas
que antes no nos hubiéramos podido
imaginar y que hoy día son una realidad
todo esto empezó porque cuando mi madre
tuvo un accidente quisimos encargarnos
que la tecnología se usará para prevenir
el dolor de las personas y comenzamos a
hacer estas prótesis que
la verdad son una experiencia
espectacular cuando ves a alguien que
llevaba 10 años en una silla de ruedas y
de repente se levanta con estos robots
hechos por otros robots y que de repente
lo veis dar sus primeros pasos es algo
espectacular y es que es el punto con la
tecnología la tecnología no es buena ni
mala hace
2000 años la pieza más avanzada de
tecnología era poner a un montón de
changos con escudos y lanzas uno al lado
del otro y eso había conquistado el
mundo hoy día
no sé cuando aprendimos a aficionar el
átomo se pudo haber usado para dar la
energía barata y limpia al mundo o para
destruir hiroshima y nagasaki la
tecnología no es buena ni mala las
personas que la usan son las que son
buenas o malas y los robots están siendo
fabricados por nosotros están
aprendiendo de nosotros cuando pusieron
una inteligencia artificial a twitear y
aprender de esta red social en unos
cuantos días era racista y tenía un
vocabulario insoportable que es lo que
le estamos enseñando a estos robots
vamos a llegar al futuro utópico o al
futuro donde buscan extinguir nos es por
esto que yo quiero decirles que en
realidad depende de nosotros y desde
esta época en la que la tecnología más
avanzada era la legión hoy que tenemos
robots en marte se agarramos una persona
que viviera 74 años y pusiéramos una
después de la otra
si nos damos cuenta solamente hay 26
personas detrás de nosotros nosotros que
somos la 27 y que estamos parados sobre
los hombros de todas esas personas
tenemos la responsabilidad de
encargarnos de crear un mejor futuro
muchísimas gracias nosotros estamos aquí
depende de nosotros a dónde vamos a
llegar